today I'm going to give you the top ten
Nintendo switch games for kids
guys the switch is by far the console my
son and I play the most together
Nintendo has long been one of the most
family-friendly game makers out there
which games rose to the top of our list
let's get to it people of the internet
retro here and welcome back to the
channel now going into this it was very
important for me that the games met the
following criteria first each game on
the list supports some form of local
multiplayer second all of these titles
have been rated by the ESRB as either an
E for Everyone or e 10-plus which is for
ages 10 and up and final it was really
important to me that all the titles on
this list are actually good quality
games so all of these here are rated at
least a 70 on Metacritic and with that
let's get into list number 10 Mario
Tennis aces it seems only right to start
the list with a Mario game and in this
title he's bringing along his friends
and some enemies it may take younger
kids some time to get familiar with the
games tennis mechanics but once they do
there will be plenty of content for them
to enjoy here in aces as with all of the
Mario sports titles over the years it's
not strictly about tennis here there's
an adventure mode boss battles minigames
and of course multiplayer where up to 4
players can battle it out on the same
screen number 9 Super Mario maker - one
of the first games I ever remember
playing as a kid was the original Super
Mario Brothers with Mario maker - you
can take a walk down memory lane as the
side-scrolling platformer is as good as
it's ever been
the beauty of mario has always been in
its simplicity
the controls are incredibly easy for
anyone to pick up and play at its core
the game is about running and jumping
but as any diehard Mario fans know
there's an insane amount of depth to the
gameplay even within the simple control
setup oh and then there's the ability to
make your own courses this is where you
can let your child's creativity run wild
as they build their own levels and
considering the game allows up to 4
players at a time you can all enjoy it
together number 8
Pokemon let's go Pikachu and let's go
Eevee it would be very
difficult to make a list of
family-friendly games without including
pokemons somewhere on the list now it's
true pokemon is mostly a single-player
experience but it does a pretty good job
of teaching younger players the basics
of role-playing games it's also not only
a single-player experience this time
around pokemon let's go brings two
players together on the same screen to
work cooperatively for the first time in
a Pokemon game it's somewhat limited but
the option is there and it's
particularly great for really young kids
who are just starting out I gave let's
go pick at you an Eevee the not over
Pokemon sword and shield because the
latter doesn't have the same co-op
features of let's go
that being said both Ark games kids and
adults should enjoy number 7 overcooked
- now I have to confess I haven't
actually played overcooked two but I
absolutely want to it is definitely on
my knee to buy a list on its surface the
objective is simple work in teams of two
to prepare certain dishes and see how
many you can get in a given time frame
it doesn't take long for things to get
wild and frantic as you'll both be
barking out instructions to one another
in real time in this one it's important
to embrace the light-hearted nature of
it so the kids don't get too caught up
in the winning and losing my own son
hates to lose so I may have to wait a
few years before trying this one but
it's great for the older kids and one
where parents can get in on the
competition as it supports up to four
players on screen at a time
number 6 super smash brothers ultimate
if you had a favorite Nintendo character
growing up chances are there in Smash
there are 74 playable characters and
that's not even including the
downloadable content now if you're new
to smash know that it is a fighting game
however it's done in a very cartoonish
manner you'll find no blood and gore
here
what you will find are options tons and
tons of options you can set up matches
in about any way you want to v2 or play
or free-for-all a play or free-for-all
1v1 items are no items oh and you'll
have more than 100 stages to choose from
it's a fantastic party game that can be
played as casually or as competitively
as you want
[Music]
alright guys if you'd played at least
one of the games I've mentioned so far
go ahead and let me know which one down
in the comments and if you spot one
anywhere on this list that you want to
purchase I'm also going to include
Amazon affiliate links down in the
description below now top five here we
come
number five Kirby Star allies Kirby's
appearance is just naturally appealing
to kids he's Gentiles a giant pink
puffball he just has a way of setting
them at ease and just as Kirby can set
kids at ease so too does Kirby Star
Allies which is a very forgiving game it
takes quite a few hits for him to die
and there's also Kirby's unlimited
flight ability that allows him to fly
over numerous obstacles in your path the
game also has a ton of power-ups and
plenty of levels to keep things fresh
you can also play through the entire
game together with up to four players on
the same screen
my only knock on Kirby is there are a
few minor mechanics in the game that can
be confusing for young kids even me as
an experienced gamer there were a couple
of times when I had to really search
around to find the answer to one of the
obstacles in our path those moments are
few and far between though and this was
one of the first games my son and I
played together and we have nothing but
fond memories over number four super
mario odyssey okay so this one is best
enjoyed as a single-player experience I
admit but my son had such a blast
playing and I had such a good time
watching him that I couldn't not include
it on the list there is a co-op mode but
it's fairly limited a second player can
take control of Mario's sidekick
throughout this game his hat
kaby but even my son who is four at the
time grew bored of it pretty quickly if
you want to try out the co-op mode I'd
actually recommend you let your child
take the primary control while the
parent handles cabie you can always
switch it up if you need to later on
kids can also enable the assist mode
which gives Mario more health displays
objective markers on screen and is also
more forgiving when you fall off a stage
you
lose a single heart and set up ending
Mario's life instantly this is a
fantastic feature that I am so glad they
added to the game for young kids and
overall guys this is honestly one of the
best games on the Nintendo switch
platform period kids or no kids
were three Mario Kart 8 deluxe in the
age of online gaming we just don't see
split-screen games too often anymore not
true for Mario Kart up to four players
at a time can race on the same screen
Mario Kart also supports numerous
control options that you can even use a
single joique on as a full controller if
you want to make room for everyone well
chances are you probably already know
about Mario Kart all you need to know
about this iteration for the switch
though is that the series is as fun and
frantic as ever in terms of specific
child-friendly options the game makes it
very easy to enable an auto steering
mode as well as an auto acceleration
mode which can be so helpful for young
ones playing for the first time number
two Super Mario Party now look if we're
just talking in terms of quality it's
true Super Mario Party is not the second
best game on this list the reason I put
it number two though is because if
you're looking for a night of fun for
the whole family for a variety of
different age groups then it's hard to
beat Mario Party if you've played any
mario party game before you know how
this goes everything is set up like a
board game and as you progress your
group will compete in various minigames
along the way it's a familiar formula
but it's ultimately one that works games
of ten turns take roughly an hour you
can also set it two more turns if you're
looking for a longer game this one also
supports up to four players on screen
together with all those multiple control
options that I talked about for Mario
Kart as well alright guys if you haven't
already don't forget to hit that like
button before you go and then give me a
drumroll here as we get ready for number
one no surprise animal crossing new
horizons it's only been out for a month
but my son and I have already made
numerous memories playing Animal
Crossing together we prefer to play
separately and watch one another but the
game does include a co-op mode for up to
four players where you can walk around
the island and perform certain tasks
together the game teaches math fosters
creativity inspires kids to learn about
nature and gives
an entire island to work on projects
together it's been the source of
numerous smiles and laughs for my family
over the past few weeks and I can't wait
to see what new Island memories will
make going forward so guys there it is
my top 10 Nintendo switch games for kids
now I know I missed some of your
favorites so be sure to let me know
which ones down there in the comments
and he found this video helpful don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
ring the bell before you go that's gonna
be it for me today I will talk to you
again soon